our wilderness survival there's nothing
better to get your blood pounding and
your heart racing even if you're only
experiencing dangerous situations they
carry asleep through TV shows like
survivor man first aired on the
Discovery Channel in 2004 the premise of
survivor man is simple
one man is dropped in the wilderness and
left to survive for seven days using
nothing but his wits and a sharp knife
but how realistic is it really to get
the real scoop we talked to Les Stroud
from survivor man and he set the record
straight about reality TV and what it
actually takes to survive it's real
first things first
survivor man is by all accounts the real
deal Stroud comes from a background of
teaching wilderness survival but as he
puts a survivalist don't know how to
make a TV show and television crews
don't know jack about survival nobody
was doing it and the ones that were done
just this fact there's just bad videos
on stuff and I just said you know what
I'm a filmmaker and I'm a survival
expert why don't I put the two of them
together other survival shows have come
after survivor man but according to
Stroud they're all done by what he
describes as TV people they care about
doing things that look cool on camera
and get ratings but they aren't
interested in teaching actual skills get
lazy Stroud stresses of every decision
you make in the wild needs to be weighed
against its energy cost see a possible
food source a mile away it's better be
enough food that is worth the hike and
how do you even know that's a mile away
this leaves four situations where that
Ridge you may be looking at just hangs
on the horizon and never gets any closer
while you waste your entire day chasing
a wild goose or sheep yeah before you
know it it's dark and you don't have any
food or shelter the one time to ignore
that advice is when you're being chased
by a wild animal drought has been chased
out of the jungle by a wild Panther and
in situations like that running suddenly
becomes acceptable
that's because maintaining your energy
levels won't matter if you don't survive
the next five minutes now that's just
common sense man versus wild could get
you killed and surprisingly there's no
lost love between Les Stroud and Bear
Grylls of man vs. wild throughout often
calls out elements of man vs. wild that
he considers fake like the numerous
allegations that bear grylls will build
a shelter on the show but then takes a
helicopter to a hotel for the night or
that a rafted built had been
pre-assemble
by the crew this raft needs to be strong
but it also needs to be big enough to
support me in the sea swell strauder
told us are trying to recreate some of
the stunts on man vs. wild could get you
seriously hurt or killed in other cases
the survival tricks are just useless
like trying to squeeze drinkable water
out of elephant dung let's drought took
Cerreta to clarified upstone saying that
most likely someone poured water over
the dung before Grylls drank it also
yuck survival myths are just as
dangerous hollywood is notorious for
showing us things that look great on the
big screen but work completely different
in real life if you ever thought ups
drinking the water out of a cactus was a
handy survival tip for the desert you
couldn't be more wrong with a barrel
cactus that you're thinking of is
actually filled with a vile liquid that
will make you puke dehydrating you even
more and drinking your own urine
reintroduces toxins into your body also
yuck
again so what about starting a fire
drought favorite method so what would
you what would you do differently ah
just nothing to carry big butane lighter
that sounds a lot easier than rubbing
sticks for an hour movies look cool but
no one should be watching them for tips
on how to survive a real worst-case
scenario experiment when Stroud hears
about some new survival trick he doesn't
try it out at home he tries it for the
first time in the wild and films it what
this means is that sometimes our viewers
witnessed him fail spectacularly first
when one of these tricks works the
surprise is real he also throws himself
curveballs to simulate real situations
for example to simulate a broken arm
he's found one at his hands no big shock
bear it makes even the simplest jobs a
lot harder he's also taken out a second
person to see if that made the survival
situation easier or worse the answer
both manual-labor like building a
shelter and other tasks become far more
manageable but you also need to divide
all your food sources in half it also
helps with morale just having someone to
talk to can go a long way drought has
taken his son out on the show several
times and describes it as a wonderful
and educational experience it's boring
it's easy to picture wilderness survival
as one big adventure
but according to Stroud the hardest
thing about trying to survive is the
sheer boredom of it all that
reality survival extreme boredom and
loneliness combined with hunger and the
lack of sleep is a recipe for depression
in real life survival situations people
have taken their own lives the best
thing you can do is get a fire going
even if you don't need it for warm for
food a fire is the biggest morale
booster you're going to find in the
wilderness it provides a sense of
accomplishment you did something you're
surviving and the VAS goes a long way
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love thing
[Music]